on a passé au blind test maintenant et
j'accueille pour arbitrer ce blind test
mois sur philippe
m
koné
est ce qu'il ne soit alors on fait la
revanche pour faire plaisir au capitaine
de la seleçao reims brésil alors brésil
ici vous l'avez vu avec des plumes et la
france ici à dakar d'accord georges-marc
vous êtes en relais dans l'équipe du
brésil dont vous connaissez le principe
du blind test je veux l'interprète pas
le titre de la chanson je veux
l'interprète
ce soir c'est un spécial anatomy voilà
donc il sera soit que des parties du
corps
didier première chanson qui chantent
comme on l'a bien compris c'est sa
famille vous avez compris je veux le nom
du chanteur allait ou de la chanteuse
bien
mory doré bond c'est le premier qui
répond que les connaissances marque
voilà donc c'était viennent d'abandonner
ou là sur les points là un bar tous très
bien sans son numéro 3 on souffle pas
sous la douche
à
vous en prie on ne souffle pas acerbes
le public peut répondre si les invités
ne trouve pas évidemment le public de
réponse ronaldo oui offert un tel
dossier
c'est bien elle donc là ça fait donc
deux pour le brésil 1 pour la france
didier
là
n'oubliez
les grandes oreilles
des grandes oreilles
le temps
c'est qui bravo
devant la banque s'arrêteront là bas
musique petit avec des grandes
z'oreilles big baxter didier
vous auriez belle tomasi la loi no way
didier
lauryn hill a toujours temps sur la fin
bravo bravo on est à combien l'a24 c'est
la france qui gagne
la terre va bien
vous l ai dit
serge pottier blais a ripé attention
sandrine martin encore c'est incroyable
ça fait quand même cinq pour la france
et 2 pour le boisé le bravo 36 minutes
didier
alors
on va faire je pense cendres y en a on à
romane bohringer on avoue on a bâti on
va faire pour la dernière émission la
fin de l'année on va prendre toutes les
stars du blind test va être très très
chaud que cette ford michel rocard merci
catherine luciano orquera excellent eh
bien on cote
valentine celle-là on peut la voir car
j'étais père et gardien à la première
neuf classes est très fort ça serait
très fort
et voilà maintenant l'avant-dernière
attention
oui
j'ai dit ok répondu
quel score assez sa peine pourtant à
donner une revanche au brésil
le score est de 8 pour la france
com
vim karim y est maintenant il ya le
super banco dans le super banco
celui qui trouve le super banco gagne
tout le cercle même pour cissé vous
évidemment vous ferez que regagner ce
que vous aider à gagner mais ils peuvent
emporter le match grâce au superbe
encausse établissements c'est injuste
mais la vie est injuste dj qui chantent
très grave là encore le souffle pas très
grave
le mot
g
oui
votez
c'est la france donc il en ford
difficilement je suis désolé pour vous
merci merci à tous d'être venus c'était
tout le monde en parle avec thierry
lhermitte à la fiche du film de pierre
olivier scotto le roman de lui
berchem patrick bouchitey et pierre
olivier scotto mélanie
à la pige du film de crêperies cassandra
15 et le 18 la wii avec richard berry
dans leur lit
jean pierre darroussin demi d'exil
alex vines de jean françois richet de
l'amour avec gimme
yazid ali
maxxo diouf et jean françois stévenin
coudoulous actuellement en tournée et
yazid déposiez l'adij devine j'en vois
toi et c'est de l'amour
john je donnais fiche du pin de rognage
voyant ses manigances avec emmanuelle
béart
anémone agrément accordé son pardon
gildas genre grave des dames aux jeunes
vous ne savez pas de quoi vous parlez
aux éditions plon
merci jardin sandrine martin de
surprises en confidence à la comédie de
paris plus en scène par ahmed gmail et
sandrine matin et bientôt d'autres au
président a atteint 6,1 à partir d'une
liste arrive à la rai ex-capitaine du
tgv
l'association bose electra voilà c'était
fondamental
rendez vous la semaine prochaine